My grandpa loves to fish.
I love to fish, too.
Grandpa and I go fishing together.
I get the fishing poles.
Grandpa gets the worms.
Grandpa and I get the worms and the poles.
We get into a boat.
We go out onto the big lake.
We go out onto the big lake to fish.
I get my fishing pole ready.
Grandpa gets his fishing pole ready.
We get our fishing poles ready to fish.
Grandpa puts a worm on my hook.
Grandpa puts a worm on his hook.
The worms are on the hooks.
We toss the worms and hooks into the water.
We wait for the fish to bite.
We wait and wait for the fish to bite.
A big fish bites my hook.
A big fish bites my hook and I pull it in.
I pull the big fish into the boat.
We take the big fish home.
Grandpa cleans the big fish.
Grandma cooks the big fish.
We all eat the big fish.